[Music]
love death and robots beyond the aquila
rift is an episode that will have you
questioning your own existence the 16
minute short is one of the standout
pieces in the series and whilst it
didn't break my recent top 5 list it
still is definitely an episode that
deserves a lot of attention throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the episode's history inspiration and
ending this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't had a chance to watch it yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I'm definition
and welcome to the channel where I
explain it so you don't have to do
beyond the aquila rift is actually
inspired and adapted from the book of
the same name and by Alastair Reynolds
beyond the aquila rift is a collection
of short sci-fi stories that similar to
love death and robots all have their own
things that can be taken from them
interestingly Zima blue 2 appears in
this collection which is of course
another episode from the Netflix show
the book in question now beyond the
aquila rift is shorthand for the trip
that no one hopes to ever make similar
to the Netflix episode the original
story features a group ripped out of
time and space separated by millions of
light years that are haunted by ghosts
from their past and struck with the
realization that life is they now know
it is just a fantasy similar to this the
60-minute Netflix show is set in the far
distant future when humans have created
technology that is advanced enough to
slingshot us across the universe we
follow the crew of the Blue Goose who
sail on a journey across the Stars on
their way to a high-profile job however
they awaken months later to find
themselves vastly of course and in near
uncharted areas of space after a mistake
by their course controller Archangel not
all seems lost though when the captain
of the ship Toma reunites with the lost
love from his past named Greta who
appears to have rescued the maroon ship
and brought it into a safe space station
on the surface it seems like it was
written in the stars and that to
reconnect amongst the vastness of space
and begin building a relationship once
more however Tom's crewmates Uzi seems
to know is that something isn't quite
right with Greg
and when awakening from sedation she
screams that Greta is not what she seems
and tries to harm her cutting her neck
in the process later in the episode
after spending a night with her
Tom notices that the cotton Gretz neck
has disappeared and he confronts her
about it which is when she reveals that
Tom is in fact still lying in hypersleep
in his tank all that he experienced
since waking up has been a simulation
and whilst Greta didn't lie about them
being adrift there isn't really much
hope for his survival now Greta or at
least the thing behind her doesn't
really strike me as a malevolent
creature and she concocted this fake
reality in order to keep Tom believing
that he can still find happiness even
though he's doomed whilst she warns him
that should he be freed from the
simulation he would not like it Tom
still protests until she shows him where
he really is at a nightmarish hive
drifting through space
it appears that Greta was right and we
see that tom is drastically malnourished
close to death and extremely fearful of
his surroundings
Tom sees Susie who looks to have
recently died and he witnesses Rey who
was completely skeletal which explains
why Greta would not allow him to be
awakened earlier in the episode we hear
greta's voice and no it was a female
like figure approaching Tommy however as
it gets closer we witnessed that it is
in fact a giant spider like creature
that is terrifying to look at to me the
hive is a space spider web that catches
off course ships and used them for food
supplying them with vivid fantasies in
order to keep them complacent Tom is
doomed and the episode ends with him
waking up from his tank once more as he
is greeted by the apparent rescue of
Greta those who have hoped for the
character and think that this may have
just been a bad dream or quickly shown
flashes of the hive to submit that Tom
is definitely doomed and still trapped
on the horrifying location borstal about
this nightmare until he inevitably dies
what's most distressing is that Tom only
really has two options he can either
accept the simulated world and live
there until he dies or continue
rejecting it and we lived the same drama
until well he dies it appears that the
spider slowly does this to its victims
one by one which is why earlier in the
episode Susie came to the
eugen that Greta wasn't real as she
appears dead at the end clearly she has
been through the process before Tom and
this is why she woke up hill in the
initial awakening whilst the spider
isn't necessarily a villain it's pretty
obvious she's keeping the crew subdued
in order to feast on them more easily
the spider states that she's been
through this countless times with many
lost souls and that she does care for
them so perhaps she implements these
simulations in order to ease their
passing in the end the spider will no
doubt go through this process countless
more times as when Tom sees the truth
there are a number of other ships stuck
in the net clearly archangel has sent a
large quantity of travelers there and
whether this is on purpose or not it
doesn't seem like it will stop anytime
soon
it took the Blue Goose hundreds of years
to arrive there despite it only being a
couple of months for those on board so
it's safe to assume that the other ships
we see traveling through the transport
at the start may have been there for
hundreds of years before Tom and the
cruise arrival in that time of millions
of ships may have traveled through the
archangel successfully so the Blue Goose
may just be viewed as a statistic
simulator ships that go missing amongst
the ones that don't overall it's an
extremely chilling episode and it stands
strong as one of the top ten ones from
the series if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my top-five list of the season which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again protect the time
to watch this you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]